la siguiente tabla muestra información
del mercado de trabajo del país x este
es el número de empleados aquí tenemos
los desempleados ficcionales
desempleados estructurales los
desempleados cíclicos y los que no se
encuentran en la fuerza laboral calcula
la tasa de desempleo en el país x
muestra tu razonamiento pausa en el
vídeo y traten de pensar en esto por su
cuenta
bueno la tasa de desempleo va a ser
igual al número de personas desempleadas
que es la suma de los desempleados
friccional es estructurales y cíclicos
dividida entre el total de la fuerza
laboral que es la suma de las personas
empleadas más las desempleadas
recordemos que nos piden esto
representado como un porcentaje y
también quieren que mostremos nuestro
razonamiento así que esto lo
multiplicamos por 100 % a que será igual
esto el número total de personas
desempleadas es de 10.000 más 5.000 más
5000 y lo dividimos entre 180.000 más
10.000 más 5000 más 5000 esto lo
multiplicamos por 100 % y es igual a 20
mil en el numerador entre 200 mil en el
denominador y todo lo multiplicamos por
100 %
esto es igual a 0 punto 10 multiplicado
por 100 lo que nos da una tasa de
desempleo del 10% veamos el siguiente
inciso calcula la tasa de participación
de la fuerza laboral en el país x
muestra tu razonamiento nuevamente pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo por
su cuenta
recordemos a qué se refiere la
participación de la fuerza laboral es el
número de personas que están en la
fuerza laboral entre toda la población
económicamente activa es decir el número
de personas que están en la fuerza
laboral más las personas que no están en
esta fuerza laboral así pues en el
numerador están todas las personas que
podrían trabajar tienes no sólo
económicamente activos pues aquellas
personas que no tienen la edad
suficiente para trabajar o personas que
están encarceladas o internadas en
alguna institución o personas en la
milicia y no olvidemos que hay que
expresar esto como un porcentaje así que
lo multiplicamos por 100 resolvemos esto
la fuerza laboral es la suma de todas
las personas que están empleadas y que
están desempleadas es justamente este
denominador de acá 200.000
lo dividimos entre la fuerza laboral que
ya encontramos 200.000 más las personas
que no están en la fuerza laboral que
son estos 100.000 todo esto multiplicado
por cien por ciento esto es igual a dos
tercios por el 100% escribimos 66.7 por
ciento aunque realmente es 66.666 que se
repite pero lo redondeamos para
simplificar la cantidad 66.7 por ciento
es la tasa de participación de la fuerza
laboral veamos el último inciso dibuja
una gráfica con etiquetas de la curva de
posibilidades de producción para el país
x donde el eje horizontal sean los
bienes de consumo y el eje vertical sean
los bienes de capital indica un punto en
la gráfica llamado zeta que refleje el
nivel actual de desempleo pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo vamos a
resolverlo juntos y vamos a hacer más
espacio para nuestra gráfica en el eje
horizontal están los bienes de consumo
lo dibujamos y nos dicen que los bienes
del capital están en el eje vertical y
se ve más o menos así y como es una
curva de posibilidades de producción
estas curvas típicamente
son así ahora nos piden encontrar un
punto en la gráfica llamado zeta que
refleja el nivel actual de desempleo
esto es bastante interesante porque aquí
dice que es un punto en la gráfica por
lo que quizá piensen que debemos colocar
el punto en algún lugar sobre la curva
de posibilidades de producción pero ese
no es el caso en este ejemplo pues
existe cierto nivel de desempleo cíclico
lo vemos en este renglón de la tabla
esto quiere decir que la producción está
por debajo de la producción potencial de
este país así que el punto z va a estar
por debajo de la curva de posibilidades
de producción no importa en qué parte de
la gráfica sea con que dibujemos el
punto se está por debajo de la curva de
posibilidades de producción será
correcto y como nos piden mostrar
nuestro razonamiento además de que
siempre es bueno hacer las cosas
apropiadamente y con mayor razón si esto
fuera parte de un examen ap donde nos
califican irán puntos por hacer las
cosas bien vamos a poner el título a la
gráfica esta es la curva de
posibilidades de producción del país x y
con esto terminamos